the fictional rules invented by humans
and this is true they were invented by
humans and when you are honest about it
it enables you to change the rules which
is being done in football every now and
then it's the same with the fundamental
rules of a country you can pretend that
the rules came down from heaven dictated
by God or whatever and then you can't
change them or you can be like you know
the American Constitution which starts
with with the people the American
Constitution lays down certain rules for
a society but the amazing thing about it
it does not pretend to come from an
external Source The Ten Commandments
start with I am your lord God
and because it starts with that you can
change them
you know the tenth commandment for
instance supports slavery the tenth
commandment in the Ten Commandment it
says that you should not covet your
neighbor's house or your neighbor's wife
or your neighbors slaves
it's okay to hold slaves according to
the Ten Commandment it's just bad to to
covet the slaves of your neighbor now
there is no 11th commandment which says
if you don't like some of the previous
ten commandments this is how you go
about amending them which is why we
still have them unchanged now in the U.S
Constitution you have all these uh
rights and rules including originally
the ability to hold slaves but the
genius of the founding fathers of the
United States they had the humility
to understand maybe we we don't
understand everything maybe we made some
mistakes so we tell you that these rules
did not come from Heaven they came from
us humans we may have made a mistake so
here is a mechanism for how future
Generations can amend the Constitution
which was used later on to for instance
amend the Constitution to ban slavery